[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
before we start this video i just wanted
to mention that only 20
of you are subscribed so if you enjoy
the content please consider subscribing
to support the channel near the
beginning of harry potter and the
deathly hallows
the wizarding world was in turmoil the
imminent threat of voldemort and the
death eaters
meant that not only witches and wizards
were in danger but muggles too
knowing that the danger would eventually
stretch beyond the confines of the
wizarding world
hermione granger knew that she would
have to make a difficult choice
hermione was a prominent figure in a
fight against voldemort
and this made her a target and by
extension her family
as well and when things really started
to get out of hand
she was struck with the crushing
realization that everything going on
would affect her parents
this prompted her to take action action
which was very differently represented
by the books and films effectively what
hermione needed to do
was erase her parents memories this
would disassociate them from her
and possibly save their lives as they
couldn't possibly reveal information
about someone that they had never met
for dramatic effect
the film really put a lot of focus on
this scene while the book only sort of
mentioned it in passing
in the book hermione says to harry i've
also modified my parents memories
so that they're convinced they're really
called wendell and monica wilkins
and that their life's ambition is to
move to australia which they have now
done
that's to make it more difficult for
voldemort to track them down and
interrogate them about me
or you because unfortunately i've told
them quite a bit about you
hermione's actions prompted the new
couple deemed monika and
wendell wilkins to act on their ambition
to move
packing up their belongings and heading
straight for australia
this also happened just in the nick of
time as the home of hermione's parents
was visited by deathly to corbin yaxley
shortly after they had left
had he been successful in finding them
that i'm sure that the death eaters
would have been able to
very successfully leverage the lives of
hermione's parents
so it's good that she took action when
she did as we can see from what hermione
says to harry
she doesn't seem to mention a particular
spell that she used
or indicate that this is an irreversible
process it's obviously sad
and she doesn't want to do it but it
doesn't seem like she's done something
that can't be undone
in the film however it's really quite a
dramatic scene it's dark
dull dreary and devoid of happiness
hermione's mum calls her for tea
and when hermione wanders into her
parents living room she quietly utters
the words
obliviate pointing her wand at the back
of their heads
this immediately begins to strip the
room of anything pertaining to hermione
as her image from the family photos
fades away and she is effectively taken
out
of her parents memories this raises a
couple of questions
first of all did hermione ever fix her
parents memories
the answer to this question is yes and
it was actually mentioned in the books
that she always had every intention of
finding them and fixing their memories
after explaining to harry that she
stripped their memories she follows up
with this
assuming i survive i hunt for the
horcruxes i'll find mom and dad
and lift the enchantment if i don't well
i think i've cast a good enough charm to
keep them safe
and happy wendell and monica wilkins
don't know they've got a daughter
you see jk rowling also confirmed in a
web chat
that hermione did in fact eventually
restore her parents memories
she was asked the question was hermione
able to find her parents and then do the
memory damage
to which she responded yes she brought
them home straight away
okay so we know that they got their
memories back hooray
but this is also where it gets a bit
hairy the undefined spell that hermione
uses in the books
is clearly described as something that
you can undo however
in the films she used abeliate which is
irreversible
this is a bit of a major oversight on
film's part as it directly contradicts
the book
jk rowling even says in an interview
they are two different charms
she has not wiped her parents memories
as she later does to dolorhov and raoul
she has bewitched them to make them
believe that they are different people
this makes things a little bit more
confusing and i'm really not sure why
the film
used obliviate but i expect that once
again we can just hash it down
to book and movie differences and a
desire to increase a level of dramatic
effect
obliviate just has such a resonance when
it's uttered
however i do want to look further into
the minutia of memory charms and how
they work
many years before hermione performed the
memory charm on her parents
a memory modification charm was also
historically used by party crouch senior
on bertha jorkins when jawkins visited
the crouch estate
she discovered that the crouch family
were keeping their convicted death
eater's son
marty crouch jr inside of their home
under the imperious curse
yes said crouch his eyelids flickering
again
a witch in my father's office bertha
jawkins
she came to the house with papers for my
father's signature he was not at home
winky showed her inside and returned to
the kitchen to me
but bertha jorkins heard winky talking
to me she came to investigate
she heard enough to guess who was hiding
under the invisibility cloak
my father arrived home she confronted
him he put a very powerful memory charm
on her
to make her forget what she found out
too powerful
he said it damaged her memory
permanently and it turns out that it was
crouch's memory charm that led to the
forgetfulness
that jorkins had been known for however
it turns out that voldemort would still
able to extract information
from dawkins despite her memory being
terribly damaged
my master had found out that i was still
alive he had captured bertha jorkins in
albania
he had tortured her she told him a great
deal
she told him about the triwizard
tournament she told him the old aura
moody was going to teach at hogwarts he
tortured her until he broke through the
memory charm that my father had placed
upon her
she told him i had escaped from azkaban
she told him my father kept me
imprisoned
to prevent me seeking my master what
this tells me is that the memory charm
that hermione used
was probably never all that useful had
voldemort really wanted to find
hermione's parents
he would have easily been able to lift
the enchantment and find out what he
needed to know
crouch wanted to permanently remove
information from bertha's mind
but that still didn't seem to work so
given the fact that hermione used a
milder version of this charm
then i really don't expect that it would
have held up if voldemort captured them
but here's the thing hermione altered
her parents memories for a couple of
reasons
not just to keep them safe as we've
addressed but also to prepare her
parents
for a reality where she may not exist
hermione knows that she's in very
dangerous circumstances
and that she's embarking on a very
dangerous venture she knows that she may
die
and by removing herself from her parents
memories altogether
she's able to more comfortably move
forward with her task
knowing that her parents won't have to
deal with the grief of her death
hermione did the kindest thing she could
do for her parents
as if they were unable to remember their
daughter then they would never have to
live their lives with the emotional
distress
of not knowing what had happened to her
after the second wizarding war had ended
hermione found her parents straight away
and restored their memories at this
point they returned to england
and just a few years later gained both a
new son-in-law
ron weasley and grandchildren rose and
hugo
had the wizarding war ended differently
life would have been very different for
the grangers
or should i say the wilkins the parents
that found their daughter to be quite
peculiar
but were proud of her all the same and
that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you